land und brecht
[Musik]
guten morgen sichert guten morgen markus
wo erreiche ich dich immer in der
kemnather
urlaub vorbei rehren la ja bist du so
flo bis zum sommer flow bist du
entspannt bis du locker bist du lässt
ich wollte heute mit ihr über müssiggang
ja ja wir haben dass eine palette neuer
geräte aber aber ich muss vorher mit ihm
etwas anderes sprechen es gibt schon
wieder aufregung na ja sie müssen sich
den müßiggang zerstören ich hatte
tatsächlich vorgehabt im juli mache ich
gar nichts oder nur dinge die spaß
machen und die irgendwie nichts für
dabei zu tun haben und jetzt habe ich ja
vor drei wochen zusammen harald welzer
angefangen ein buch zu schreiben
aus aktuellem anlass und das buch
analysiert bestimmte mechanismen wie
unsere medien funktionieren
ja ja ja und weiter zusammen liegen da
ist für spaß gesorgt und ich meine mir
war ja schon bei der berichterstattung
aufgefallen bei der migration dann
nochmal bei corona jetzt von krieg und
so weiter da gibt es so viele dinge an
denen man gut erklären kann wie die
medien funktionieren und auch ein paar
sachen über die man sich sorgen machen
muss und deswegen schreiben wir dieses
buch und es interessanter ist da gibt es
tatsächlich schon journalisten die haben
das schon quasi rezensiert und zwar auf
eine kleine ankündigung im buchreport
hin dass angekündigt welcher und
rechtschreiben ein buch über die medien
und dann wird schon vernichtend geburt
eilt ohne eine zeile also normalerweise
machen rezensenten das so sie tun so als
hätten sie ein buch gelesen und
rezensieren mir hat aber ich hatte ja
das ist böse natürlich nein aber
manchmal passiert es ja tatsächlich und
hier ist es das muss man sich mal
vorstellen so dass jeder weiß dass sie
es noch gar nicht gelesen haben und es
trotzdem rezensieren also das ist das
ist sozusagen ich glaube dass das
kabarettistische was ich bisher erlebt
habe und ich finde es auch schade also
da gibt es eine frau in ihr heißt miriam
hollstein
von t-online dir also die hat mir schon
leidlich werden schwob lager ohne eine
zeile gelesen zu haben und ich frage
mich was geht im kopf von jemand vor der
sich selbst für jemand als die
religiösen journalisten hält ein urteil
aufgrund einer vorankündigung zu
schreiben und zwar noch ein so
holzhacker richters und so dämliche
urteil also da hat werde ich wieder
bestätigt man muss sich um den
journalismus in teilen sorgen machen ich
habe das nicht gelesen ich kenne auch
die autorin nicht ich hab gelesen das
stück von joachim huber im tagesspiegel
joachim huber kennst du ja ich mag ihn
eigentlich ganz gerne ich fahre mit ihm
zehn jahre lang in der jury vom adolf
grimme brachten okay und da haben wir
die dinge auch oft sehr ähnlich gesehen
und dann war er als wegen meiner
aussagen im hinblick auf impfpflicht und
so weiter da hat er eine andere meinung
oder kinder impfung und da hat er mich
unglaublich aggressiv angegangen wo ich
mich dann völlig gewundert habe und auch
der hat jetzt schon wieder über die
stränge geschlagen und schon üble
unterstellungen gegen die autoren
veröffentlicht ohne eine zeile gelesen
zu haben dann war ich mehr sagen ich
mache mir da einfach sorgen um die
qualität unseres
weiß warum ich lachen muss gerade weil
das ist der erste satz des textes von
jochen huber nennen wir sorge ja
schon weiß dass es keine echte sorge
sein soll ohne es gelesen zu haben ich
meine das ist ein bisschen wahnsinn ja
ich also ich muss ihnen der pass auf
joachim huber muss ich eine sache dazu
sagen der der grund das habe ich gar
nicht so genau verfolgt das joch im ober
die ich angeblich so kritisiert hat in
der korona zeit du kennst die geschichte
von joachim huber das gespräch mit
joachim huber über corona einer der
nicht im verdacht steht ein besonders
eitler mensch zu sein einer der nicht
dem verdacht steht sich im fernsehen vor
zu drängeln oder sowas
ganz im gegenteil lange lange haben wir
an ihm herum gebaggert um ihn dazu zu
bringen möglicherweise bei uns muss eine
geschichte zu erzählen joachim huber ist
fast gestorben der ist ganz ganz schwer
in kuwait 19 erkrankt ist beatmet worden
lag wochenlang im koma ist eine
bewegende geschichte wenn man das hört
und insofern verstehe ich warum er ein
thema mit corona hat und alles was in
die richtung sozusagen von relativierung
geht ich verstehe dass er da an gefasst
ist und möglicherweise sogar ein
bisschen befangen also das kann ich auch
verstehen aber warum dann in dem moment
ein ein feindbild entsteht bei leuten
die die eine oder andere frage beim ohne
anders sein riesiger persönliches ein
bild nicht dieses feindbild sich so
dermaßen zementiert dass man sich traut
eine quasi vor rezension zu schreiben
die gar nicht auf den inhalt eingeht
sondern deren funktion darin besteht die
beiden autoren zu diskreditieren
also sowas macht kein anständiger
journalist also ich habe das gelesen ich
habe das tatsächlich interessant da die
wahrnehmung ich ich nehm das so nicht
wahr ich hab' ich habe blöde überschrift
gelesen buchautoren üben scharfe kritik
und dann kommt der entscheidende satz er
sagt sogar die schreiben anklage buch
über die vierte gewalt ich glaube so
wird also heißen der gruppe der reihe
nach scharfe kritik woher weiß er dass
zweitens klage buch er hat mit dem buch
was wir schreiben überhaupt gar nichts
zu tun zwei unterstellung bereits nach
26 ich habe ein wort darin gesehen und
das ist das wort von dem ich glaube das
ist bei herrn huber und auch bei anderen
was getriggert hat und ehrlich gesagt
bei mir auch ich spreche und welzer sie
in medien als zitat selbst
gleichgeschaltet und das offensichtlich
ein wort das im klappentext auftaucht
ist nicht unwichtiger text den autoren
üblicherweise eigentlich gar nicht
selber schreiben aber ich das ist ein
wort bei dem ich denke hoops was ist das
das kann ich verstehen sind nicht gut
es gibt menschen bei denen das
assoziationen
ja das ist das allerletzte was wir
vorhaben
wir versuchen ja auch gerade zu erklären
dass es nicht der staat ist ja der von
sich aus jetzt verlangt dass alle
irgendwie hofberichterstattung machen
oder seine meinung wiedergeben sondern
worüber wir reden es ist nicht gleich
schaltungen sondern selbst angleichung
der medien das wäre das wirklich
passende wort also falls ja noch selbst
gleichschaltung steht der satz sollte
schnellstens verschwinden okay aber
selbst angleichung der medien auch
interessant ja das ist nicht tragisch
phänomen wie es im klappentext steht
noch ein anderer interessanter satz und
deswegen und wir werden immer mal
ausführlicher aber das buch sprechen
aber dieser gedanke ist natürlich
interessant wie mehrheitsmeinung gemacht
wird auch wenn sie keine ist
das ist tatsächlich so also das haben
wir jetzt ganz eindeutig bei der
berichterstattung beim ukraine krieg wir
haben mehrere meinungsumfragen was
denken die leute halten sie schwere
waffen für das richtige mittel oder
nicht und die ist das so bekannt wie mia
wir haben sie die letzte umfrage war 45
dafür 45 dagegen zehn prozent
indifferent aber wir haben eine
veröffentlichte meinung und das kann man
sehr gut nachweisen von über 99 prozent
dafür und das ist eine in der geschichte
der bundesrepublik historische
situation dass die öffentliche meinung
die pari pari es und die veröffentlichte
meinung die hyper eindeutig ist so weit
auseinanderklaffen und dadurch entsteht
natürlich wenn die medien alle der
gleichen meinung sind oder fast alle der
gleichen meinung sind jedenfalls die
kommentatoren die politischen
journalisten chefredakteure und so
weiter dann entsteht ein asymmetrisches
verhältnis von veröffentlichter und
öffentlicher meinung und dann wird
tatsächlich medial eine meinung quasi
produziert schall verstärkt die nicht
identisch ist mit der öffentlichen
meinung wenn meine frage richard und da
habe ich jetzt schon wieder ein problem
wie mehrheitsmeinung gemacht wird wohl
sie keine ist haben medien haben
kommentatoren die aufgabe zu beschreiben
was mehrheitsmeinung ist oder ein sie
haben sie haben nein sie haben den
ansprüchen einer die liberati vcn
öffentlichkeit zu genügen die libera
tief heißt teilnehmt na das ist ein
zauberwort einigen sich alle
medienwissenschaftler kommunikation alle
drauf also öffentlichkeit muss die
libera tief sein das heißt transparent
seien die impulse der bei der
bevölkerung müssen sich in den medien
widerspiegeln und es muss eine
repräsentation der öffentlichkeit eine
angemessene repräsentation der
öffentlichkeit in der veröffentlichen
meinung geben das ist konsens also ich
kenne niemand der dem widersprechen
würde und wenn du 99 zu 50 fifty hast
dann ist ist hier tatsächlich ein
problem entstanden und dieses problem
ist mal gucken wie ist das entstanden
wodurch ist es zustande gekommen und
vielleicht auch was kann man zukünftig
dagegen tun also 99 prozent halte ich
für wahnsinnig hoch gegriffen ich
versuche jetzt gerade mein kopf
irgendwie unsere eigene sendung so
durchzugehen ja aber im moment ein
kleiner unterschied mache ich rede nicht
von den auftritten die gäste haben
sondern von also wenn ich bei der sitze
dem weißt ja ich habe eine andere
meinung oder das glas bilder genau oder
ulrike borodina wolfgang nicht die
fragen hat merkel unterseite jetzt
angelangt ich weiß ich weiß sie saßen
übrigens im regelfall und in den meisten
situationen alleine gegen eine überzahl
von menschen die das anders sie würde
ich auch muss man das will ich nicht
bestreiten okay aber sehr wichtiger
punkt ist ich rede gar nicht von den
gästen oder gastkommentator ja das hat
einige kommentare von habermas geben in
der süddeutschen zeitung einen langen
doppelseitigen essay von ilja trojanow
und so weiter es gibt mehrere beispiele
dafür aber es gibt keine oder fast keine
solche kommentare von chefredakteuren
auslandskorrespondenten politischen
redakteuren und so weiter und davon dass
ich weiß ganz ganz generell ich habe das
buch nicht gelesen deswegen muss ich mir
auch nicht an ein urteil zu fällen ich
habe nur und und das noch abschließend
dazu eine frage hast du nicht sorge dass
das sozusagen genau diesen sound
befeuert der seit corona seit der
finanzkrise seit 2005 10
amerikas an stichworte praxis ist ein
stichwort die situation in frankreich
ist ein stichwort hast du nicht sorge
habt ihr nicht sorge dass das genau
diesem sound vorschub leistet der da so
lautet ja ja die da oben die stecken
sowieso alle unter einer decke die
medien die spitzenpolitik dann noch das
böse staatsfernsehen die berichten ja
sozusagen auf anweisung du kannst dir
nicht vorstellen wie oft ich gefragt
werde
welche themen vorgegeben werden er und
wem die uns vorgegeben werden ja und es
wird häufig als gesetzt angenommen und
ich krieg dann immer verwunderte blicke
und ich sehe auch in diesen blicken wir
glauben dass zum teil nicht wenn ich den
sage den leuten selbstverständlich
schreibt uns niemand weder beim zdf noch
ihren von der bundesregierung dass wir
ja völlig absurd vor was wir zu machen
haben da mal was anderes aus dem
nähkästchen wenn du
die die geschichte unserer sendung
anschaust die gab es ja immer wieder
situationen wo gerade auch
spitzenpolitikerinnen und -politiker
irgendetwas gesagt haben von dem sie
schon direkt im anschluss an die sendung
wussten ja das könnte ärger geben ich
kann dir sagen und das ist wirklich
interessant es gab vielleicht zwei oder
drei versuche in hunderten und tausenden
gesprächen wo leute versucht haben mir
nahe zu legen noch klein ist vier augen
gespräch im nachhinein
können wir das nicht irgendwie
rausschneiden oder können wir da nicht
irgendwie usw ansonsten habe ich das
niemals erlebt ich erlebe im gegenteil
an den großen großen respekt speziell
bei leuten aus der ersten reihe und zwar
quer durch alle parteien wirklich durch
alle parteien das gilt für herrn leuten
genauso wie herrn merz das geht für lars
klingbeil und viele andere an den großen
respekt davor dass die dinge
selbstverständlich die unabhängigkeit
von medien ernst genommen werden muss
und das und das ist meine frage an
seiner hauptfrage war ja leistet man
damit nicht denjenigen die dem staat und
der von ihnen so genannten lügen presse
ja nur noch das übelste und gemeinsame
sache zu genauen vorschub und ich sage
dir die antwort gegen diese leute ist
das buch geschrieben
ja das verstehen das thema ist wenn in
den medien mechanismen wirksam sind oft
gar nicht durchschaut die bei anderen am
ende die illusion erzeugen es handle
sich um weisungen von oben ja oder um
eine organisierte lügen presse dann
haben wir ein problem
die frage ist kann man das vielleicht
besser vermeiden und das ist das thema
ich erkläre in dem buch in aller
ausführlichkeit
warum diese verschwörungstheorien von
lügen presse und stark macht und so
weiter und alles ist auf weisung gemacht
und so warum die vollkommener käse sind
das ist ein thema in diesem buch
es zeigt aber auch wodurch wie
strukturen entstehen die zu diesem
missverständnis in der wahrnehmung
beitragen können und wenn man an diesen
strukturen vielleicht etwas ändern
könnte dann hätten wir diesen verdacht
nicht mehr auf die üble art und weisweil
genau wie du mache ich mir sorgen wir
kommen in eine zeit in die nicht besser
wird als in der vergangenheit sondern
wir kommen wahnsinnig unruhige zeiten
und in diesen unruhigen zeiten sind wir
auf zwei dinge angewiesen auf sehr sehr
gut funktionierende massenmedien auf der
einen seite und auf den zusammenhalt der
bevölkerung ja und die verstärkung des
sozialen kids damit er nicht weg
bröckelt und wir keine verhältnisse wie
in den usa kriegen weil davor habe ich
ganz ganz viel angst und ich halte das
für eine realistische gefahr und gegen
diese gefahr ist das buch geschrieben
ich meine
deswegen dieses thema dieses dieses
unbehagen also ich finde das gut dass
man sich darüber gedanken macht und ich
finde es auch gut dass man das mal
genauer untersucht und dass man
mechanismen von massenmedien versucht so
durchdringend und zu verstehen und du
hast natürlich recht diese diese
amerikanischen verhältnisse wollen wenig
gutes beispiel ist ja hierzulande auch
der kanzler ja also es ist eigentlich
mittlerweile völlig egal ob olaf scholz
sagt wir machen eins zwei drei vier fünf
in hinblick auf die ukraine wir liefern
1 2 3 4 5
da draußen ist festgefahren dieses image
dieses bild des zögerns des zauderns und
dem roberta das quasi nicht bewusst aber
das habe sie medien gemacht dieses bild
ja vielleicht ist nicht einfach mal so
volkes stimme das mag der eine oder
andere so gesehen haben aber wir haben
wirklich kollektiv ja also kann es die
zeitung durchgehend egal ob es jetzt
süddeutsche oder auf das welt ist oder
ob das der spiegel ist und so weiter die
alle ja den der scholz dargestellt haben
als den zögerern ja der wenn er so
weitermacht tausende von toten in der
ukraine auf dem gehweg das hatte ich so
verkürzt wirklich nicht stehen lassen
richard ich lese immer wieder auch und
ich mache mir wirklich ein gericht im
ort wieder lockt wenn er sagt der machen
neue waffenlieferungen und das kommt
fassen aber er in sein wird hier nicht
nur kommentiert sondern die ich merke
dass die chefredakteure in den mund und
leitartikler ja in die ohren der rolle
sich sehen den kanzler zu bestimmten
entscheidungen und zu bestimmten
verhaltensweisen nach möglichkeit zu
treiben und damit über ziehen sie den
bogen ich bitte noch mal ein spruch also
weißt du was das auch insinuiert
deswegen auch dieses wort der selbst
gleich schaltung ist ist in st das war
okay ich vergesse es ist in ordnung dann
dann streichen wir das einfach aber ich
verstehe warum ihr auch im uba damit ein
problem wenn es selbst an gleich okay
dann dann hat vielleicht jochim hubert
es jetzt auch gehört und hat eine andere
idee davon aber ich verstehe sein
problem damit ich bin noch etwas anderes
sagen euch hat sozusagen diese these
auch das was du gerade sagst dass
insinuiert so ein bisschen das ist eine
irgendeiner form eine absprache gäbe so
als wären da selbst wenn es nicht
politik und medien es gibt keine
absprache war auch kein es braucht keine
absprache sagt aber was ist das einfach
machen ich habe da so alles wichtig ist
das klar zu machen versuche ich zu
erklären die eines selbst angleichung
der medien möglich ist ohne dass es sich
um weisung oder absprache hat welt das
versuche ich zu erklären wie das ganze
aus sozusagen dem demokratischen diskurs
der medien heraus entsteht
und ich glaube dass wir damit was
wichtiges leisten weil weil wir da was
machen wir damit wir weisen die
leitmedien daraufhin dann genauer auf
sich selbst zu schauen und wir ziehen ja
den leuten die zähne die glauben eben
dass das alles eine große verschwörung
ist weil das ist es definitiv nächten
genau das ist das der punkt um meine
sorge ist nur wird wir sind da glaube
ich relativ nah beieinander meine sorge
ist nur was du in zeiten in denen es nur
um headlines geht und ins um ein paar
zeichen bei twitter geht in denen
sozusagen halbe überschriften geht die
man mal eben so liest und dann aber
meint informiert zu sein und es sofort
wieder weitergibt und hunderttausendfach
millionenfach teilt es ist natürlich
brandgefährlich wenn der eindruck
entsteht da gibt es sozusagen diese
medien die sind sich da alle einig die
sprechen sich irgendwie alle ab und so
weiter mitnichten ist das so die aussage
der super star jack lehrer dass es
absprachen dafür gar nicht braucht es
gibt absprachen de das ist das
interessante dass bei ducati von amerika
sagte ist sagte die sinclair broadcast
group was richard das ist ein ein ich
habe mich mal mit dem beschäftigt schon
schon vor monaten da ging es auch um die
wahl und so weiter und den zustand in
amerika das ist ein
medienunternehmen amerikanisches sie
sitzt in hand welche die haben 179
fernsehsender ja das nennen die
sozusagen ihr eigen das ist eines der
grössten rundfunkunternehmen in den usa
erreicht gut ein drittel aller
us-haushalte
und da gibt es doch sehr interessant ist
wird vor allen dingen sozusagen zwischen
ost- und westküste gehört also ja in den
ganzen staaten dazwischen da wo
vorzugsweise auch sehr konservative wo
tom tailor sitzen und sinclair schreibt
das war zumindest in der vergangenheit
so und ich wüsste nicht warum es jetzt
anders ist diesen stationen
sogenannte mass kranz vor das sind
zentral verfasste botschaften berichte
texte ideen gedanken die die jeweiligen
moderatoren dann gefälligst zu
präsentieren haben es ist total irre ja
also ja ich kann mir vorstellen dass im
frühjahr 218 gab es so ein bericht
da ging es um fake news usw um die
tendenziöse berichterstattung in
bestimmten medien usw das wurde dann
landesweit von denen einfach so
ausgebreitet ich meine wenn du mal an so
einem punkt bist dann wird es schwierig
also diese punkte hat es überall schon
gegeben also die hat es in guggenberg
konzern gegeben in den 20er jahren
betrugen berg einer der steigbügelhalter
hitlers der große medienschar der
weimarer republik der ein
ultranationalist war ganz übel in
amerika ja also der berühmteste
zeitungsverleger aller zeiten
internationales first ja die kennen
viele weil er das vorbild war für den
außen wells film citizen kane exakt so
und der wollte damals dass die usa in
einen krieg gegen spanien 1800 90er
jahre eintreten in dem kampf um kuba und
hat ein vorfall von dem völlig unklar
worum es da geht also das glaub ich ein
schiff detoniert benutzt und sofort den
spaniern die schuld gegeben und dann hat
er seine journalisten nach kuba
geschickt damit jeder recherchieren
irgendwie welche spanischen agenten na
das attentat von ihm traumhafte so den
sabotageakt so die kamen zurück und
sagten wir finden nicht die geringsten
indizien dafür und dann sagt er jetzt
vater noch mal hin hier sorgt für die
bilder ja und ich sorge für den krieg
da er wollte diesen krieg und durch
diesen krieg ist die auflage seiner
zeitungen in rekordhöhe
hochgeschnellt das heißt dieser völlig
idiotische blöde krieg ist letztlich
tatsächlich in diesem fall von einem
zeitung star ausgelöst worden aus
persönlichen geschäftsinteressen also
das ist so das gras ist ja viele
beispiele also das hat ja auch in
england solche zeitung style coole
gegeben und da steht natürlich immer die
gefahr hinter das macht ohne missbrauch
ihren reiz verliert ja einmal so mächtig
ist der überzieht auch gern in den bogen
aber
das was wir hier als beispiele haben das
ist nicht die situation vor der wir in
deutschland heute stehen ja also wir
haben wir haben nicht
zeitungs tycoon diesen zuschnitts wir
haben auch nicht bei dem einen oder
anderen verlagshaus meinungsfreudige
verlagschefs genau weiter über das liga
wie auch sein das ist ja völlig in
ordnung dass dürfen kinder das dürfen
sie wollen die sogar sein könnte sogar
sein der die frage ist immer nur ein
korrektiv für alles das ja ist die
liberati für öffentlichkeit also das ist
eine öffentlichkeit die durch die
veröffentlichte meinung auch adäquat
repräsentiert ist und das ist ein
wichtiges kriterien ich fand nur noch
ein satz sozusagen in eigener sache dazu
richard ich lange nachgedacht über das
haben wir auch schon mal in der sendung
darüber gesprochen sozusagen die stimme
derer die das alles kritisch sehen und
so weiter kommt gefühlt gefühlt quasi zu
kurz ich habe das meinem blick auf
unsere eigene sendung die auch angesehen
das mag tatsächlich so sein und ich
verrate kein geheimnis wenn ich sage es
ist wahnsinnig schwer diese leute in die
sendung zu kriegen also da gibt es leute
die schreiben briefe und dann lädt man
sie danach ein und sagt lass uns doch
mal darüber reden weil man weil wir der
auffassung sind ist es wichtig über
diese ja soweit sie in einem offenen
brief und auf meiner brieftasche genau
ich bin da sind auch zum beispiel die
die die haltung von jemandem wie dietmar
bartsch von der linkspartei und anderen
ja unter janine wissler zum beispiel ja
die kann man sagen dass alles
durchgeknallt und geht es ihm um diese
putin verstehe und so weiter kann man
sagen wenn man das diskreditieren möchte
auch das ist zu billig finde ich das ist
so einfach und es ist wenn der punkt ist
sicher mit den leuten auseinander
gesetzt aber der platz wo wir es gibt ja
auch ein grund dafür weil es im
regelfall so ist und ich selber habe
wenn ich talkshows gesehen habe
mit ausnahme die im unseres gesprächs
was ihr jetzt zu zweit hatten aber davon
meist abgesehen hatte ich jetzt kein
beispiel vor augen wo diejenigen die
schwere waffenlieferungen der die fonds
schwerer waffen für das falsche mittel
halten und ihr die jetzt einen großen
diplomatischen vorschuss des westens
anmahnen dass man das machen sollte dass
die in einer sendung gleich von der
person anzahl besetzt sind mit
denjenigen die die gegenteilige meinung
haben was ich hab noch nie zwei in einer
sendung das macht sie auch üblicherweise
nicht so läuft das machst du
üblicherweise weil wenn ich nein nein
nein also nicht ob ich kann nur auf
unsere sendung sprechen aber du lernen
jetzt doch auch du lädst doch auch auf
der anderen seite drei oder vier mit
anderer meinung ein du lebst einen mit
der meinung ja
waffenstillstandsverhandlungen so
schnell wie möglich ein und drei oder
vier die eine andere meinung haben wobei
in der bevölkerung die meinung wie
vorhin schon gesagt fifty fifty stoffe
und es weiß was und zweitens zu dem
thema warum sich keiner traut wie auch
immer dorthin geht hat nicht nur das
problem dass er da in eine minderheit
gerät sondern hat das große problem dass
die leitmedien ihn anschließend
verreisen werden und er auf twitter
persönlich aufs heftigste angegangen
wird und da stellt sich dann die frage
irgendwann warum soll ich mich einer
solchen situation aussetzen und da muss
man schon nicht nur rhetorisch sehr gut
sein sondern auch in super
selbstbewusstsein haben ja ok gebe ich
dir recht aber bitte wir reden jetzt
hier über profis also tut mir leid diese
gefühligkeit an dem punkt wo da gibt es
drei böse twitter kommentare sollte mal
zehn also erst auf twitter irgendwas
alleine über mich schon geschrieben
worden könnte ich längst irgendwie hatte
ich mich auf offene irgendwo bis in
höhen die ich bin dass ich auch
gemütlich aber es gibt leute die haben
ja mein gewesen ein richard das ist
falsch man gewöhnt sich gewinnst du dich
daran ich nicht ich merke dass die
gewöhnlich daran weil ich gar nicht mehr
auf twitter gucke
der gewöhnung ist ignorieren ja ja ist
richtig aber lasst uns bitte doch
ehrlich sein es ist doch nicht so
dass dich das kalt lässt ich merkte dass
doch immer ich höre schon direkt ohne
guten morgen sagt weis ich okay ich
hatte ja hatten kaffee auf oder wer mich
aber ich habe wirklich seit monaten seit
monaten monaten konsumiere ich keine
sozialen medien ja aber ich will nur
sagen durch hat mir geht dieses
wehleidige an dem punkt wirklich auf den
senkel jeder wir stellen uns nein
richard wagner nur den gedanken habe ich
gleich auf regen wir stellen uns ganz
nach vorne die wiki bereiten raus
sozusagen mit einer position wir
schreiben briefe schreiben gegen briefe
wir haben meinung wir haben gegen
meinung okay so und dann kommt ein
bisschen wind von vorne und dann ist
direkt wieder juli jetzt sind sie will
ja alle böse zu mir er tut mir leid ich
komme da nicht mit also ich erkläre ich
hätte
ich für mich ist immer dann gut wenn ich
merke ich wird von allen seiten
gleichmäßig beschimpft und beleidigt
dann weiß ich hab mein job einigermaßen
gemacht ich mache mir nur sorgen wenn
jetzt ausschließlich von einer seite
kommt das finde ich schwierig weil dann
weiß ich okay da war ich nicht
ausgewogen genug also es ist ein großer
unterschied ob man so mit in medialen
stahlgewittern gehärtet ist wie du und
schon seit ewigkeiten damit leben muss
das hat man nicht nur viele fans hat
sondern genauso viele hater oder bei mir
ist das ja eher nicht oder ob du ein
feinsinniger intellektueller wisst ja
philosophieprofessor juraprofessor
professor für internationales recht und
was weiß ich was der sich eigentlich
ohnehin nie in die öffentlichkeit begibt
also jedenfalls nicht in talkshows und
so weiter und der dann anschließend
nicht nur die kids stores bei twitter
sich anhören muss sondern auch in den
leitmedien aufs übelste von leuten
angegriffen wird häufig von fachkollegen
die nicht entfernt die gleiche
reputation haben
und das sind situationen in denen diese
menschen die damit die laien in der
akademischen welt leben ja die die
überhaupt nicht kennen und überhaupt
nicht gewohnt sind und die ganz anders
als wir beide auch gar nicht trainiert
sind damit umzugehen dass solche leute
sich da nicht in das haifischbecken
einer talkshow wagen ja das kann ich mir
gut vorstellen aber ich für meinen mann
gesagt und spricht ja auch nichts
dagegen zwei leute die den offenen brief
unterzeichnet haben einzuladen und zwei
leute einzuladen die das völlig anders
ja ich verstehe den punkt und der letzte
bei dem ihr das so klar geworden ist ist
er von von mir wirklich persönlich sehr
geschätzt der reinhard merkel zum
beispiel der
nach dem auftritt in der sendung der
hatte eine ziemlich große fläche und ich
habe ihm die chance gegeben das zu
erklären und es kommt ja immer wieder an
diesen diskussionen an diesen einen
punkt was schlagen sie den dann
stattdessen vor und das ist halt der
moment in der argumentation der bis
heute bis heute gab es für mich noch nie
eine konsistente antwort von niemanden
aber weißt du markus ich möchte etwas
dazu sagen weil dann bringst du ja
häufig als argument wenn die gut sind
die gäste ja und nicht so redlich wie
sie das meistens sind ja dann spielen
sie die den ball zurück und sagen welche
lösungs perspektive haben eigentlich die
realistische lösungs perspektive die
meinen man müsse den krieg durch die
lieferung schwerer waffen noch
verlängert die haben auch keine lösung
perspektive seit die perspektive weg ist
dass die ukraine das alles zurückerobert
also insofern tun sich die beiden
parteien in der frage überhaupt nicht ja
wir könnten wir jetzt auch lange darüber
streite ich wollte nur gerade auf was
anderes hinaus richard ich wollte nur
sagen mein punkt ist es ist doch völlig
in ordnung eine andere meinung zu haben
und ich bemühe mich auch immer dieser
mahnung raum zu geben ich versuche auch
immer so zu sagen dass du mich mal in
die schuhe von olaf scholz zu stellen
weil natürlich muss jemand wie olaf
scholz
sich überlegen was bedeutet es wenn
irgendwann mal russland am rande einer
militärischen niederlage wäre als
beispiel was ist in ein paar jahren was
ist in einer möglichen nach putin ära
und es gibt nur zwei möglichkeiten
entweder wendet sich dieses riesige land
und es ist zu groß um es nicht
ernstzunehmend wendet sich entweder
china zu und wir sehen das gerade dass
das eigentlich schon passt richtig und
haben ein echtes problem oder aber wir
eröffnen ihnen eröffnen ihm die
perspektive sozusagen in die arme des
westens zu kommen was ehrlich gesagt die
viel schönere perspektive werden wir
basierend vorbei
war kein anja im velo und die russen
sehen sich ja glücklicherweise also ich
rede nicht von putin und unsere jungs
ein paar sein die sehen sich als
europäer die die da gibt es ein tiefes
gemeinsames verständnis und das ist ja
nicht die hofft sicherheit sicherlich
den europäern wesentlich näher wie in
der bevölkerung als den chinesen ihr
reden zumindestens vom europäischen teil
des landes also reden jetzt nicht von
der mongolei ja so friedrich sozusagen
also gleich sein eigenständiger staat
aber sozusagen nicht von denen von denen
gebieten die überwiegend von asiatischen
bewohnern geprägt sind aber im
europäischen teil ist das auf jeden fall
sorgen ich war da brauchen wir gar nicht
lange darüber zu streiten natürlich
müssen wir russland irgendwann eine
perspektive bieten aber die frage wird
natürlich sein unter welcher russischen
führung unter welchen bedingungen unter
welchen veränderungen die dann in der
ukraine passiert sind so und da haben
wir mit so viele variablen zu tun dass
wir auch nicht sagen können dass in drei
jahren in fünf in zehn oder zwanzig
jahre ich bin um richard einem ist schon
ein paar minuten her einem eindruck
wirklich deutlich entgegen treten es ist
nicht so und das und da bin ich mir auch
ganz sicher für für die kollegen und ich
rede jetzt wichtig nur über das genre
talkshow ist ehrlich gesagt auch antwort
dass ich hasse lasst uns
gesprächssendung sagen ja ist das viel
bessere wort und lasst uns auch das ding
mit der show weglassen bei show ist auch
eine chance das überhaupt nicht ich mich
bei dir sowieso keine chance mehr habt
ja nicht mal mehr zuschauer
doch ich musste ja dem gerät gerade habt
ihr einige millionen aber ihr habt ihr
die nicht unmittelbar und mittelbar im
studio war es natürlich ein großer
unterschied macht weil es den show
charakter deutlich reduziert
und ich mag das wort talkshow ja auch
nicht gibt leute die sagen also die mich
schon als showmaster oder oder talkshow
host bezeichnen die aber in einem eins
zu eins gespräch unter vier augen was
ich in meiner sendung führen ja ich weiß
ich ich bezeichne mich als talkshow
horst aber das ist was an ja ich
wollte nur sagen ich wollte dem eindruck
entgegentreten dass das sozusagen
gezielt so eingeladen wird so nach dem
motto da brauchen wir jetzt einen der
ist gegen schwere waffen und dann haben
wir vier andere die sind dezidiert für
schwere waffen so ist das nicht erklärt
auch einfach mal umgekehrt erklärt
nochmal wie die besetzung tatsächlich
zustande kommt das war dass diese
intransparenten ist doch das beste war
ja jetzt tun
genau wie im einzelnen ist es so also
leute manchmal etwas krude vorstellung
davon wie so was es geht
eigentlich ist der anlass beispielsweise
um jetzt bei reinhard merkel zu bleiben
mit dem offenen brief ja gegen diese
schweren waffen uniformen dann ist
dieser brief dann gibt es diese these
wir nehmen wahr und das ist halt auch
genau wiederum das was sozusagen auf der
habenseite der medien steht und das geht
anderen
magazinen und sendungen genauso die
nehmen wahr dass es da diesen brief gibt
die sehen diese meinungsumfragen die
merken okay da gibt es da draußen
offensichtlich ein land das gespalten
ist das nehmen wir ganz genau war und
wir merken auch dass ich das so ungefähr
die balance hält was er besitzt er nicht
irgendwo im luftleeren raum jeder von
uns hat freunde jeder von uns für
private diskussion darüber jeder von uns
liest andere medien und versteht schon
ziemlich genau was da draußen passiert
so dann sagt man gut das ist interessant
das ist auch eine wichtige meinung und
deswegen lass uns doch bitte mal mit
herrn merkel sprechen und dann kommt ich
kann die ehrlich gesagt jetzt aus dem
kopf nicht sagen während der sendung
noch wahr dass das können wir mal kurz
werden wir hier sprechen herausfinden
soll dann kommt natürlich die frage auf
ok gibt es dann die gegenposition die
gegenposition kann eingenommen werden
von einem politiker wie zum beispiel
lars klingbeil der sohn eines
berufssoldaten der der anders
argumentieren würde und dann gibt es mit
sicherheit noch also mit blick auf
unserer sendung die rolle des
beobachtenden journalisten wo ich häufig
zum beispiel erlebe dass jemand sagt
kluge leute wie anja maja und andere ja
die sagen dann was auf den punkt würde
ich herrn merkel nicht recht geben aber
dann kommen andere einlassungen und dann
sagt dieselbe anja maier
da bin ich aber eindeutig jetzt auf der
seite von wolfgang merkel dass ich aber
ganz anders als herr klink oder wie auch
immer in die in dem fall
kevin kühnert guck mal spd habe ich
vermutet ich krieg das gerade von lukas
ihr netter weise danke robin alexander
war dabei gut gerne ganz klare
dezidierte meinung mein rad genau dann
reinhard merkel der auf der anderen
seite ist und dann yanar polieren die
auch eher auf der seite von
waffenlieferungen ist aber so wir haben
zwei noch in der seite von waffen ja
ganz ganz kurz ja aber jana polieren die
nicht dafür da ist um vor allen dingen
den armen herrn merkel in den senkel zu
stellen sondern dies da um sozusagen die
militärische lage in der ukraine
einzuordnen das ist der punkt und welche
meinung sie zum thema schwere waffen hat
oder nicht aber ich glaube kevin kühnert
es auch für die waffenlieferung also wir
haben verhältnis von 3 1 aber kevin
kühnert kevin kühnert also auch da tu
ich mich schwer einfach zu sagen kevin
kühnert ist für schwere waffen die
verhalten also sagen wir mal der
situation na ja es gab aber frei die sie
über heuer tut mir aber es gab fast
keinen einzigen abgeordneten ganz
wenigen ausnahmen abgesehen bei der
abstimmung abwarten ich weiß nicht wie
viele waren es zwei oder drei leute in
der spd die nicht dafür gestimmt haben
ich habe das ist ja nochmal was anderes
mich hat das ist mal was anderes
doch dafür wenn ich dafür stimmen naja
ok
kultur ist viel zu schlau um
das nicht so versteht und ich werde
jetzt auch nicht über dieses elende
stöckchen springen lassen da gerade
hinhält so einfach ist es doch nicht du
weißt doch dass die leute sich alle
quälen jeder fühlt sich erst mal als
abgeordneter aus einem gewissen
verpflichtet dass es im mögen auch seine
aufgabe und natürlich gibt es aber dann
einen kanzler der jetzt eine verdammt
schwierige moralische weitere
schmerzhafte entscheidung zu treffen hat
oder es gibt keine gute lösung es gibt
nur schlechte lösungen und ganz
schlechte lösungen ist ja völlig an
meine meinung dass meine ich und wenn du
deswegen ist das ganze interessant jetzt
also in dem fall ich könnte die andere
sendungs konstellation zeigen da wird
vielleicht sogar anders aussehen
aber in jedem fall will ich nur sagen da
gibt es nicht und das ist mein punkt es
gibt nicht und das gibt es auch nicht
bei anne will und auch nicht bei sandra
maischberger und auch nicht bei frank
plasberg es gibt nicht sozusagen den
großen bösen plan dahinter und jetzt
treiben wir es mal in diese richtung
überhaupt gar nicht also den großen
bösen plan glaube ich auch nicht spricht
ja entspricht ja hab ich nicht da ich
weiß ja ja er war es ist doch das was
ich vorhin gesagt hat und damit es zu
einer asymmetrischen besetzung in
talkshows kommt braucht es keines großen
bösen plans und es braucht schon mal gar
nicht irgendwelcher weisungen von seiten
der regierung ja die da an den fäden
zieht und dann ruft der intendant an und
sagt ihr besitzt das aber jetzt mal
anders genommen also das ist mir dass
ich klar und eben ja aber muss ja
trotzdem erklären wie es dann gleich
wohl passieren kann und das ist eben das
was mich persönlich interessiert weil
ich ja weiß dass es so holzschnittartig
eben nicht punktgenau und jetzt zum
beispiel diese sendung mit ihr die
konkreten mal anguckt ist wirklich
interessant ja napoleon hat meine
erinnerungen immer wieder was angeordnet
aber nicht so wahnsinnig hohe anteil
gehabt derjenige der in dieser sendung
und das weiß ich ziemlich genau ich
hab's nicht gestoppt aber das ist mein
gefühl und man versucht das auch in dir
in die richtung zu steuern wenn man
merkt okay da ist eine alleine mit
seiner position aber es ist eine
wichtige position der der mit abstand am
meisten geredet hat in dieser sendung
war ganz sicher reinhard merkel davon
gehe ich auch aus so und ich nehme auch
an dass du eben die gelegenheit gegeben
hat seine position darzustellen aber
eben b auch im wesentlichen werte 'ran
gesehen hast was auch dann aufgabe ist
seine position an zu zweifeln oder die
schwachstellen aufzuzeigen
wenn das dann noch so ist dass er aber
keinen echten unterstützer in der
sendung katalonien hat er ja nun nicht
gehabt und die anderen sich dann doch
mehrheitlich in den meisten dingen einig
sind dann kommt der schwierige position
so jetzt kann man sagen ja das ist halt
so in talkshows das kann auch immer
meine sich erfüllt und das kann auch in
der dyna talkshow mit reinhard merkel
genauso in der sendung in der es in
seiner geschwister kann nur nicht sein
ich weiß nicht wie viele
gesprächssendungen ist zum ukraine krieg
bisher gegeben hat aber ich schätze gut
während es gewesen sein es kann nicht
sein dass das in allen 100 immer das
gleiche besetzungs verhältnis ist das
kanal ihn sein nein das ist ja auch
richtig so aber weißt du umgekehrte er
auch nur du weißt ja dass ich selber und
es machst du doch auch richard ich meine
wenn du wir haben das doch mal gelernt
und wir machen das auch schon lange man
hat ein gefühl für eine bestimmte
situation
und natürlich ist es so dass man dass
man manchmal dinge falsch einschätzt um
himmels willen wir sind alle menschen
und wir sind sehr sehr mit fehlern
behaftet und ich ganz besonders gerne
aber wenn ich sozusagen etwas immer
wieder versuche dann ist es doch dies
dieses dieses alte dialektische prinzip
irgendwie umzusetzen ja also wenn da
jetzt zum beispiel anton hofreiter sitzt
und und erzählt mir genau wie das jetzt
mit den waffen ist und leitet es auch
noch ein mit dem satz also ich kenne
mich ja mit waffen wirklich nicht aus
aber und dann kommt eine liste von von
schweren waffen inklusive der berühmten
panzerhaubitze 2000 von der der anton
hofreiter ganz genau erklären kann was
sie macht provoziert das bei mir
natürlich den satz also dafür dass sie
angeblich keine ahnung von waffen haben
wissen sie ganz schön viel das sage ich
ihnen dann auch so und ich frage dann
auch kritisch dazu tragen nach der
pazifistischen tradition seiner partei
usw und er hat damals und weil er da
natürlich auch diese kritik an nimmt
gesagt ja sie haben recht aber passen
sie auf wir sind nicht nur die partei
des pazifismus wir grüne sondern wir
sind auch die partei der menschenrechte
unter dem punkt seiner der besten sätze
die ich rund um diesen konflikt gehört
habe weil er einfach genau den punkt
macht um den es geht und wenn es wenn
uns sehr über das würde ja natürlich
sagen ja macht den punkt dann ja wenn
seine panzerhaubitzen dazu beitragen die
die situation der menschenrechte zu
verbessern und nicht zu verschlechtern
das ist die variable über die man
streiten kann er richtig über die kann
man sehr sehr lange streiten und da
haben wir ja leider alle keine glaskugel
und wissen nicht wer es am ende ausgeht
ich hatte abschließend noch gefragt ich
wollte mit jährlich über müssiggang
spricht also muss man gelesen machten
keine zeit für müßiggang genau
ganz grundsätzlich er wenn ihr sowas
untersucht und jemand auch wie du dir ja
soviel auch in den medien ist und von
den medien ja auch lebt und natürlich
auch genau weiß sozusagen wie medien
funktionieren ist nach da nimmt dafür
halten die deutsche medienlandschaft in
einem bedauernswerten zustand oder in
einem eigentlich noch ganz guten zustand
ich sagte nachher wie ich es eher ruhig
sagt ich hab ich finde ja quasi den
internationalen vergleichen also im
internationalen vergleich muss man sagen
so viele qualitätszeitungen wie
deutschland fällt mir kein zweites land
ein
situation des öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunks ja im vergleich zu viele nicht
zu allen aber vielen anderen ländern wo
es tatsächlich echtes staatsfernsehen
gibt ja oder wo es an dieser stelle fast
gar nichts mehr gegen auf sinclair
brokers group genau also ich natürlich
ist unsere medienlandschaft sehr sehr
viel besser als in den usa
ja sie ist er besser als die
medienlandschaft in england sie ist
besser als die medienlandschaft in
italien oder in spanien also im
internationalen vergleich stehen wir
sehr gut da aber du kennst das ja ich
meine viele form der kritik die wir zum
beispiel an der politik in deutschland
haben ja wenn wir politiker oder politik
kritisieren dann ist das immer auf einem
ziemlich hohen niveau im vergleich zu
den sorgen die die menschen in drei
viertel der anderen länder der welt
haben das bedeutet aber umgekehrt nicht
dass man wenn man sich tendenzen sieht
wobei denke hier entwickelt sich was in
die falsche richtung dass man das auch
aufzeigen muss und das hoch interessante
daran ist wenn man mal schaut ja was die
wissenschaftler die sich mit unseren
medien beschäftigen und du wirst staunen
wie viele es gibt ja ich weiß wie viele
lehrstühle gibt es für publizistik
kommunikationswissenschaft
politikwissenschaftler die sich mit
medienfragen beschäftigen zeitungs
wissenschaftler das gibt's ja alles und
die haben ja untersuchungen gemacht ja
die haben zum beispiel berichterstattung
zur migrations krise oder zu corona
ausführlichst untersucht da gibt es ja
unglaublich viele studien und es gibt
viele dinge die von diesen
wissenschaftlern bemängelt werden
die aber nie irgendwo das licht der
öffentlichkeit ernsthaft sehen was sind
sozusagen die briefe an freunde also
wissenschaftlicher fach diskurs und nur
personal ist die welt so stark in den
medien sind können das überhaupt zu
einem medienthema machen und deswegen
ist es ja umgekehrt also nur wer eine
figur der medien es hat überhaupt die
möglichkeit die medien zu thematisieren
ist richtig das ist wenn du sagst 215
zum beispiel
was was ist da sozusagen das
interessanteste ergebnis von
untersuchungen weil ich will dass
soziales ich will ja noch nicht alles
erzählen was in dem buch steht weil du
kannst ja ganz immer gesagt meine frau
ist wird die leute interessieren also
ich bin nicht der spezialist das ist
harald der sich mit dem migrations thema
auch viel gründlicher befasst hat aber
es gab zum beispiel eine sehr
wellenförmige berichterstattung zur
krone pandemie und das für mich
bezeichnete ist das natürlich die medien
genau wie der größte teil der
bevölkerung fast geschlossen gegen eine
impfpflicht waren dann in eine kurze
phase gab etwa indem er mit einer
vehemenz für die impfpflicht gekämpft
wurde ja also da gab es wirklich also
gab es einen gleichungen die größte
mediale meinst du jetzt größte mediale
entgleisung war die talkshow hart aber
fair in dem vier befürworter der
impfpflicht ja gegen svenja flaßpöhler
in dem fall standen ja die zweifel an
der impfpflicht hatte und auch nicht
eine kollektive die neuinstallation alle
ungeimpften hinnehmen wollte die an
einschließlich eines parteiischen
moderators da an den pranger gestellt
wurde in einem ausmaß und dabei muss man
berücksichtigen
sie hat das verteidigt was zu diesem
zeitpunkt juristische realität war also
sie hat die geltende rechtslage
verteidigt ja gegen leute die also im
hauruck-verfahren ja die geltende
rechtslage geändert sehen wollten und
ist da als minderheiten meinungs- frau
eingeladen worden und auch wirklich
härtesten angegangen und die gleichen
leute die diese habe gesehen wie seine
die nicht gesehen deswegen ich habe dir
sicher dass ich sogar zweimal gesehen
und die gleichen leute zum teil die da
also ja also richtig also mit mit wärme
für die impfpflicht gekämpft haben die
wollten dann drei vier monate später als
die die der wind sich wieder gedreht
hatte nichts mehr davon wissen
und darüber ziehen die medien wenn sie
dann tun ja dass es gibt einfach dinge
da geht man viel zu weit und das hängt
damit zusammen dass wenn man ist auf der
welle ja und wenn man völlig auf der
welle ist da denkt man ja die anderen
sehen das doch auch so und dann gibt man
ordentlich stoff aber
am ende könnte das seien ja dass die
welle sich wieder verändert und dann
sind die leute wieder ganz woanders aber
die sendung bleibt ja und dieser angriff
bleibt und so weiter also die cola
berichterstattung die war sehr von
diesen wellen gekennzeichnet
ich hatte ja ich habe diese konkrete
folgen ich gesehen hab natürlich darüber
gelesen weil weil das damals der folge
war die zu sehr viel aufregung geführt
hat ich habe nur gerade jetzt mit mit
blick auf frank plasberg das gefühl wenn
jemand wirklich themen durchdringt und
dialektisch versteht was da passiert
dann ist es genau frank plasberg und
insofern weiß ich nicht wie partei an
dem punkt wirklich wahr oder nicht wahr
ich mache mir nicht also mir wir hätten
das die an die aber vorwurf der
parteilichkeit geht nicht gegen das
verhalten des moderators vogler geht
darum dass es eine sehr eigenartige form
von besetzung war ja und man das gefühl
hatte dass die vertreterin der geltenden
rechtslage hier als jemand dargestellt
wurde der eine verquere radikale
minderheitenposition die könnte mir
jetzt einfach machen sagt sich auch
einen vertreter der radikalen
minderheiten wo ja sicherlich habe ich
hab mir denn genau genau wie ich soweit
ich mich erinnern kann durchgängig immer
dafür dass ich möglichst möglichst viele
menschen impfen lassen da war ich auch
immer gegen eine ebene gehe ich mal
gegen eine impfpflicht lernte ich auch
genau weiß dass meine begründung dafür
übrig hat das ich verstehe den gedanken
dahinter ja zu sagen wir wir müssen
irgendwann mal diese quote hoch kriege
ich meine grad eben auf dem weg hierher
höre ich wieder das jetzt mitten im
sommer gehen die zahlen auf den
intensivstationen wirklich hoch aus
vielen gründen arbeiten 2000
intensivbetten fehlen wie bei vielen
pflegerinnen und pfleger erkrankt sind
und dritter punkt weil wir bei
offensichtlich eine nennenswerte zahl
von von menschen auf der intensivstation
haben die mit 19 kämpfen das ist hart
mit dem augenblick eine riesige welle
die in ihrer größe aber nicht mehr
erfasst wird und genau die haben sich
sehr viele sehr viele leute das nicht
bekanntgeben oder melden und das ist
tatsächlich so und das ist übrigens
erschreckend nah dass die zahl der
intensivbetten nicht fangen wir haben
jetzt corona seit drei jahren dass sich
das nicht erhöht hat ja auch also das
ist dass es für mich unvorstellbar ja
auch das ist da so wenig verändert hat
ich will nur sagen also die lage ist
nach wie vor das ist alles kein großer
spaß hier und und das trifft jetzt
möglicherweise auf eine glas mangel lage
auch so ein schönes wortes zu diesem
sommer gehört also ist alles gerade
nicht so richtig witzig und deswegen
verstehe ich sozusagen die die gedanken
wenn du fordern der spitze des landes
steht und sagt okay man wie machen wir
das jetzt nicht ich weiß auch wie sohn
karl lauterbach ungefähr denkt das ist
ein
ganz hohes ethos ja der der will dass es
dem land gutgeht er will dass das
gesundheitssystem funktioniert und er
macht sich tagung nach gedanken darüber
wie er das in griff kriegt so das
verstehe ich alles dass da jemand sagen
kann wir fordern die impfpflicht nur ein
punkt war immer wir können nicht um
nicht glaubwürdigkeit zu verlieren vor
der bundestagswahl und zwar einer nach
dem anderen den leuten ständig sagen
impfpflicht wird es mit mir nicht geben
und zwar vom bundesgesundheitsminister
damals ihren sparen bis hoch zur
kanzlerin alle haben das ausgeschlossen
ich glaube auch olaf scholz will jetzt
nichts falsches sagen und kaum ist das
ding vorbei sind plötzlich alle für eine
impfpflicht aber meinst wenn das auch
das daran dass das ein beleg dafür ist
weil die medien die leitmedien dann auch
ganz stark für eine nebenpflicht waren
das war dass sich die politiker heute
ich sag nur einen gesandten so dass wir
viel stärker treiben lassen als das
einmal vor 30 40 50 jahren der fall war
kaiser es gibt es gibt
politikwissenschaftler die sagen wir
leben in einer mediokre ja und damit
wollen sie sagen dass im grunde genommen
die spielregeln der medien heute in
einem ausmaß die spielregeln der politik
bestimmen oder mitbestimmen wie das in
früheren zeit nicht der fall war und das
glaube ich auf jeden fall dass dieser
befund richtig ist ja das mag sein und
trotzdem da spiele ich den ball auch
einfach mal zurück und sage und deswegen
ist es umso wichtiger dass leute die mit
der führung dieses landes betraut sind
dass dieselbe haltung meinung und auch
fakten parat haben zu dem was gerade
aktuell verhandelt wird für lohnen sich
nicht treiben lassen und an alle die das
gegenbeispiel
du siehst leute die die einfach
konsistent dass er lauter war laut
rabatte lauterbach ist ein wunderbares
bei ja zum beispiel und das so hat sich
ja gerade erwähnt also karl lauterbach
ist ein politiker der die dinge die er
glaubt tun zu müssen die extra
unabhängig daher gesagt ob er dafür in
den medien bei fallen oder masina
widerspruch der andere so was von diesem
typ politiker weiß ich ob das bei robert
haben müssen nicht länger drüber
nachdenken doch was sagt er denn
unpopuläres gegen die medien na ja also
ich sag mal den den den den alarmismus
vorwurf den fängst du dir ja sofort ein
wenn du so wie robert habe im moment
machst und waren ist und sagt frau war
am ende am ende geht das risiko ein dass
die leute umgekehrt sagen das sei nicht
hinreichend gewarnt hat also hat ein
ähnliches problem
auch mit ihnen zu tun deren folgen die
man im auge nicht abschätzen kann
deswegen eine gemeinsame corona also man
hat es wird lauter variablen zu tun wo
man nicht genau weiß dass cal irrt das
völlig oder wird es nicht so schlimm
also hast da ist der große parallele die
papa ich würde auf jeden fall karl
lauterbach für seine standfestigkeit
loben selbst wenn der meinung vertritt
die nicht immer meine sind ja genau so
kann man sagen und es um genau das aber
auch bei robert habeck der wetten dass
ist ja genau das ding die haben es im
moment mit unfassbar vielen unbekannten
zu tun und trotzdem stellt er sich hin
und sagt freunde ich sag euch
das und das kann passieren wenn es nicht
eintritt wenn er hinterher alle sagen oh
gott guck mal was hat er für ein alarm
gemacht ist doch nichts passiert weil es
eintritt wenn die leute sagen soll und
was hast du jetzt dagegen getan ist auch
alles kein problem das ding geht so dass
mit ihm nach hause und das weist er auch
ganz genau
risikoeinschätzung es ist immer noch
besser man hat ein bisschen zu viel
falschen alarm geschlagen ja als man hat
eine gefahr markus unterschätzt sichert
ja aber er ist derjenige er traut sich
sonst weit und breit nicht viele außer
joachim gauck zum beispiel der macht das
auch aber ja das ist der ehemalige
bundespräsident aber robert habe traut
sich zu sagen verzicht wer traut sich in
diesen zeiten zu sagen verzicht in einer
zeit in der die haltung der bürger zum
staat so ist wie du sie auch häufig
beschrieben hast so der dienstleister
staat ihr soll jetzt morgen fließt
liefern aber bitte keine zumutungen an
mich in dem punkt markus bin ich völlig
wunderbar wie hart ich danke dir sehr
das war interessant mal deine wirklich
für mich auch sehr lehrreich sozusagen
über du lebst ist ja häufig auch von der
anderen seite und deswegen für mich ist
eine sehr wichtige aufgabe ich dann ja
eine produktion von m 52 und posters bei
homer im auftrag des zdf